quinlan was here
yeah he helps now
smuggling youngling the bosses are back
instead
yes we got a boss back
only when the eyes are closed just read
it so i don't have to translate yeah
see what
quinlan with the wisdom
the way deep
quinlan goes this is the way this is
fire you
will suffer
oh my god
oh my god you can't burn him
he's got to look like alec guinness in a
couple years yeah your pain
that's gonna take a lot of back to
welcome back to new rock stars darth
vader just unleashed some fiery payback
on obi-wan kenobi thankfully didn't go
for the face but don't call this war
criminal merciful because he just
murdered a row of innocent mafusa
bystanders what have you unleashed upon
the galaxy
[Applause]
we forgot to do that last
week we were just trying to wake up the
hotel people who were staring down on us
like who are these two idiots on a bench
talking about
spoiling this episode yeah well this is
wikileaks it's our weekly obi-wan kenobi
after show here at new rock and god damn
it's a great time to be a star wars fan
i'm here with tommy bechtold we're back
in the blue dungeon after an
unforgettable weekend at star wars
celebration
incredible weekend you know it was cute
for months we were starved
starved for content long have i waited
but uh
all of a sudden a damn burst and we were
washed away in the in the majesty of a
galaxy far far away and here we are now
halfway through kenobi already can you
believe that i know this season's going
by too fast
they
they pitch this as like a i think i i
know obi-wan kenobi was meant to be a
movie and they're calling this episode's
part one part two part three so this
feels like we're we're watching just
like i don't know a six-hour movie or a
five-hour movie but that's moving too
fast for
me i i
need two seasons why can't they give
obi-wan kenobi 12 episodes and 12
episodes like they do and horn
we'll get some kimora b
no boy oh boy
well i have said it once tommy i'll say
i'm kasari
oh man it's too early for that yeah
sorry guys it's an exciting week here
after this episode because
vosses
are once again star wars canon
with the name drop of quinlan vos
we're gonna talk about who this jedi
survivor is why it's a huge deal that
he's alive and what it tells us about
the state of the jedi right now uh as
well as talking about all your big
questions coming out of this episode
quick recap of what happens obi-wan
meditates on his memories from revenge
of the sith and the other prequels as
vader goes through his morning routine
but whereas our man boba fett left up
back to bath every morning to wrap
himself in a nice cozy bathrobe vader's
suit seems a bit more pokey
ouch does not seem like a comfortable
way to start your day no yeah rise and
grind vader
the only thing he'll be grinding are
bones yes
james earl jones returns to voice vader
from behind the mask and what an amazing
amount of like
worry among star wars fans we're like
what's he gonna sound like it's like of
course he's gonna sound like james earl
jones i mean yeah i up until we actually
heard his voice i was like they're not
gonna do something weird are they
they're not gonna do something they
wouldn't do something weird what they
they wouldn't do they wouldn't it it's
so wonderful just hear james jones and
man despite however old that guy gets
the voice modulation they're able to do
on him to make him sound just as like
clear and uh a machine
as he did in the original trilogy he
sounds just as he does yeah in a new
hope and returning the jedi empire
strikes back so it's just so great to
hear him again uh but we'll talk about
like this balance between james earl
jones and hayden christensen's uh
their contributions to the character
we're seeing in this episode a bit later
this episode but uh from vader's castle
on mustafar uh he compliments the third
sister and it charges her with finding
obi-wan offering her the position of
grand inquisitor or killing her if she
bails the stakes are pretty high yes
sticks are pretty high there's really no
middle ground there so on the fortress
inquisitorious in the ocean world of ner
the fifth brother the fourth sister
clearly despised the third sister we
finally get a sense of the rivalry
between them the ambition among them all
because the fifth brother considers the
rank of grand inquisitor his i have a
lot of questions about the the actual
order succession and how they get their
numerical designations and what the hell
is really going on with the grand
inquisitor are we seeing a retcon here
we should talk about that yeah
right i still think we i still don't
think we've seen the last of him and
this may be one of those things where i
after episode six i'm like
i still don't think we've seen the last
of him but uh
i'm gonna i'm i maintain
by by the end of episode five the
inquisitor will be back for an epic
finale let's let's let's hope so right
um so obi-wan and leia flee to mapuzo
which is a mid-rim planet that's turned
into a mining colony that's stripped for
vitrium uh hodges coordinates actually
lead them to a remote spot uh where no
one meets them there so they get a lift
uh by freck a driver you know you cannot
trust because he's voiced by zach brad
that's right
i can't trust him
obi-wan obi-wan and leia claim to be
farmers from tall they're almost outed
when obi-wan calls leia instead of the
fake name luma calls her leia that's a
smart storm trooper for picking up on
that but obi-wan is able to do a nice
little adjustment there and say that
leia was her mother's name
and that he you know he sees her getting
this uh nice little moment where he's
clearly grieving over padme uh two
episodes in a row where we get to see
like obi-wan's grief over padme
something that you know i didn't think
that would bother him too much but of
course it bothers him someone who's very
close to him i don't hey listen i don't
like to be a town gossip and i don't
like to be you know
a stirrer of the pot but lends a little
credence to anakin's concerns that maybe
obi-wan had feelings for padme that were
stronger than he revealed you know he
seems to really have some some nostalgia
and some uh some some some some yearning
for the old padme so i don't know i i
think you know all these years anakin's
been vilified for a couple whoops of
daisies
you know a few
clubs whoops a daisies tell that to the
younglings in the training room on the
temple come on this is why i'd be a
great politician because a little bit of
time passes and i'm able to say like
look has everyone we've all made
mistakes let's not throw glass
lightsabers or throw lightsabers in our
glass houses
glass lightsabers uh i think uh yeah
clearly he has a lot of affection for
padme i think his one true love was
satine uh but i think you make a good
point that that that friendship between
obi-wan and padme was something that
anakin felt threatened by um
and we learned that obi-wan uh he has
vague memories of his own family
uh including the fact that he had a
brother
which i find very interesting yeah
something that might come up in the
future uh but then frickin frack turns
them in and obi-wan takes out a probe
droid he causes a stormtrooper to slice
in half
yikes yeah and uh i believe one of the
stormtroopers in the scene is a guy we
know from the la comedy scene shane
heartland yes allegedly
they're not allegedly according to
according to social media shane hartline
plays the stormtrooper congratulations
shane good for you got a boy and then uh
indira varma shows up as an imperial
officer but actually a rebel in disguise
i don't know if she's officially a rebel
just someone who's helping out the jedi
uh passage safe passage tala is her name
she takes them to her jedi safe house
where she says that they smuggle jedi
runaways and young lanes to the planet
of jabim and obi-wan reads all their
little like you know so and so was here
uh tommy loves eric you know these yeah
big thank you to to to temper joe for
putting in that that little easter egg
that i wanted uh of tommy loves eric so
i really appreciate her including that
it only cost me six million dollars uh
to to get in there so stay tuned yeah uh
you see all the comedians who uh who uh
performed in that weird droid junk shop
you know like a bill burke in his name
uh they all started show carved in her
name over there yeah rosie o'donnell was
there uh
weird about it
yeah
basically all the comedians who have
been on this show
is the name of the quote from quinlan
boss a very important jedi we're going
to talk about in just a bit uh who he is
why he's important but then vader shows
up and he just begins force choking the
hell out of everyone and it's pretty
hard to watch yeah um
and then he engages obi-wan in a mineral
field and he tells everyone i am what
you made me and they duel but obi-wan is
quickly
outmatched like he doesn't even get a
single good blow or a single good moment
he is weak as hell uh he's completely
overwhelmed getting thrown around like
ragdoll i mean just get this guy out of
there it's it's not gonna go well it's
like watching when mike tyson made his
comeback and they had him basically
fight like human mannequins
and they were like he'd just like get in
the ring and like punch the guy twice
and then the guy's trainer would throw
in the towel and be like get him out of
there
so uh vader force chokes him uh
causes him to drop his lightsaber and
then drags the guy across some fiery
coals
and this is brutal but luckily our you
know our man ewan mcgregor his salt and
pepper beard doesn't turn to ash because
i don't think we could handle that no no
no no no we can't see any there's no
there i didn't remember seeing any major
burn scars on him as alec guinness but
you know he's always buttoned up and he
does wear that clothes
we don't see him in a tank the way i
wish we could you know just like a nice
thin tank top and some chubby shorts
um
before vader can fully season there's an
interesting moment where vader throws
him out of the fire like he spares him
he doesn't want to kill him yet i
presume for interrogation purposes like
he the guy has his eye on the full
mission overall there's still a lot of
jedi out there and obi-wan might know
where others are he says the line
uh
like yo you're you're like you're you're
today you don't die or you're not dying
yet or something like almost implying
like he has more torture he wants to do
too like yeah he's like i i didn't get
to die
when you severely maimed me
so you don't get to die either i'm gonna
maim you first yes this fire phase is
just phase one i have phases based on
all the elements
yeah then i will be burying you in earth
up to your neck as uh weird little
scurriers scratch your face and then
next i'm gonna put you in my weird suit
machine and they're just gonna poke you
with stuff it's gonna be wild phase four
is an all-expense paid trip to endor
where we'll enjoy fabulous cocktails
served to us
by tiny little ewoks phase five is back
to torture back to torture i'm taking
you to that coruscant opera house that
show sucked in milk only cool part was
when palpatine told me all about his
cool sith history yes but you're just
gonna have to watch the opera
and then
before vader can take him on that
delightful torture parade uh tala blows
a generator that reignites the fire that
allows her loader droid to sneak in
there and drag him to safety and i just
love how these stormtrooper
stormtroopers are like oh fire back
we can't just go around this fire i
can't see anything on the other side it
seems like vader lets him go in that
moment it's like i feel like vader could
do a forced leap over that so to get
away and take them out like that felt
like kind of like hmm yeah that's some
really good some really good
credit to the adr post post audio team
to throw in some stormtroopers going
there's no way around
we can't get around like just a for
because all of us watching are like
can't you just walk 10 feet to the right
or left and go around this little patch
of fire but they made sure to let us
know that the stormtroopers who are you
know always the bastions of intelligence
and street smarts were unable to figure
out a way to get over so
i i think you heard one stormtrooper say
maybe it was even shane our man shane
might have said wow these flames are so
high even master vader couldn't jump
over it yes i'm pretty sure that was a
line yeah yeah
yeah um so leia flees through a tunnel
but ends up at the feet of the third
sister uh-oh it's all for nothing oh no
um so in this episode of wikileaks we're
going to talk about quinlan vos the
planet beam
the inquisitor's succession
whether star wars is recounting rebels
with the grand inquisitor um we're gonna
talk about uh obi-wan's brother and
whether we're really getting enough
hayden as this version of vader i wanna
i wanna talk to you about that tommy
yeah but be sure to check out the newest
latest obsession shirt released by our
merch partners at epic hero shop it's
called empire's most wanted it is
inspired by the obi-wan series once this
limited edition shirt is sold out it is
gone for good so do not miss out on your
opportunity to grab this limited edition
merch and when you get a latest
obsession shirt you will unlock the
ability to write in a custom shout out
message that will appear right here in
wikileaks what do we have today we have
meredith who says do you think we will
see anyone from the ghost crew in andor
if so who love you guys 3000 thank you
for your question meredith uh i believe
we're going to see everyone from the
ghost crew in ahsoka for sure the
timeline is there though for for andor i
mean some like harrison doula maybe uh
i just don't know if we're gonna see any
jedi i don't know if we'd see like kanan
uh or a young young ezra i mean esri
ezra would be very very young on andor
right so
um we're not that young right if it's
five we're talking about the the start
of uh when rebels begins i just don't
think we're gonna see
we might feel like they're setting them
up for ahsoka i don't it would seem
weird to
have them because they're trying i think
with andor to establish like
a different side of this fight that you
haven't seen right like we're showing
different characters and what they were
doing during this whole
rebellion yes
matthew asks do you think we will see
the wookiee chrysanton in this series if
so would he be sent by uh riva or vader
you know i the only way i think we would
see black chrysanthe is if they restaged
that moment with him and uncle owen and
luke back on tatooine and i don't know
if this show's gonna return to tattooing
maybe at the ending yeah like we find
like the final shot might be obi-wan
back in his tattooing home changed but i
don't i don't think we're going to see
i'd be surprised if we saw black cursed
at this point i feel like that window is
passed i yeah i i also think
for me
i i kind of hope we don't in this i i
don't know that like for that character
it makes sense to bring him back
to when he was like you know just like
pure fighting killing you know like what
like you know i think like we've already
seen him kind of come over to the good
side quote unquote on book of boba fett
albeit as a you know kind of a mercenary
it's like i don't know that i
necessarily am like well let's just see
him when he's heart it's be hard to
understand
for you for younger viewers i think if
he's all of a sudden just you know
trying to kill obi-wan or something but
yeah i mean i
people just fight all the time and he
seems like a bad boy so i think we could
get by with that i just feel like at
this point the series seems to have
moved on yeah from from where that would
happen yeah uh alex asks do you think
obi-wan will communicate with yoda in
this series it seems like he kind of is
or at least like remembering yoda
telling him hey don't watch the security
tapes it's going to be violent um but i
i think at this point if he can talk to
master qui-gon's force ghost i believe
he should be able to uh chat with yoda
from across the galaxy from wherever he
is to dagobah um so yeah i i think it's
very possible um
i guess we'll just have to wait and see
i'm i'm holding out for more hope that
uh yeah it'll be liam neeson though
would you say you have a cause a new
hope
now it's the same old hope i have one
hope okay and it just shapeshifts into
whatever i need it to be i have a hope
chatting when it's full of lockets
but just your face and no one else on
the other just one one side
with my face in just a question mark on
the other side
someday my princess will come
well you can find all of our awesome
merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com all right tommy
what's our lead question coming out of
this episode okay eric
this is big for you who is quinlan voss
well quinlan vos is a relative he's kin
so be careful what you say about him no
uh quinlan vos with 1s is a jedi long
believed to have survived order 66 but
now it is confirmed i'm now wondering if
quinlan voss might actually be the
character played by o'shea jackson jr
nice we'll see maybe it could be someone
else i think that'd be some fun casting
if that's indeed who he is but uh he
first appeared actually in phantom
menace before he even had the name
quinlan boss he was sitting in the
background of mosses but just kind of
watching qui-gon and obi-wan with jar
jar being like what are they doing but
uh he was really just a hooded figure
with a yellow stripe painted across his
face but fans were so fascinated by this
guy that uh the lucas story team gave
him a whole identity and backstory as
they do for so many characters uh and he
appeared in various expanded universe
rather legends stories like star wars
republic and george lucas liked him so
much from that storyline that he
included him in the script for revenge
of the sith he was meant to be on uh in
the battle of kashyyyk um where yoda and
luminar and dooley were uh he's gonna be
like uh riding a a republic tank um but
that was not in this like it was never
actually shot in the movie but it was in
the original script for it um
and uh the scene was cut but kenobi
actually does bring him up uh in
dialogue later in a different point in
the movie telling anakin master vos has
moved his troops to pause uh to boss
pity and i remember when i watched that
with my friends in 2005 and they said
master vos all my friends were like
they grabbed me and i was like i know i
know
i was so excited you're like that's me
that's me i'm in the movie
um
well quinlan actually appeared in one
episode of clone wars the season three
episode hunt for zero his role was meant
to be expanded in eight more episodes
but the series was canceled before those
were ever shot but that arc that planned
arc formed the basis of the 2015 novel
dark disciple by christy golden it's a
really really great book that explores
quinlan's romantic relationship with
asajj ventress dooku's former apprentice
who's a major major villain in the clone
wars series fascinating character um so
uh quinlan vos was confirmed to have
survived order 66 because uh the charles
soul 2017 darth vader comics that the
series is pulling so much of its
inquisitor lord from listed quinlan
vos's name among other surviving jedi
that the inquisitors were still hunting
and then later in that series on mancala
jedi farron barr mentions quinlan voss
as a possible jedi survivor that they
can turn to for help so those clues plus
this now confirming the guy still alive
and he's still helping jedi out in uh
the galaxy in these post-order 66 years
yeah a bit about quinlan he's known for
psychometry that's the ability to sense
the memories of other beings uh by
touching objects that they've come into
contact with we actually saw a visual
example this with rey and luke's
lightsaber in the force awakens um and
uh so tala indicates that quinlan is
smuggling younglings to the planet jabim
where they're given new identities since
the empire is now hunting both jedi and
just for sensitive kids this could be a
continuation of palpatine's project
harvester in clone wars remember that
that's when he used cad bane to kidnap
all these four sensitive babies in order
to uh build a sith army a project that
you could say led to the creation of the
inquisitors by palpatine uh when before
he handed that team off to vader so uh
jabim is actually a planet from those
same uh republic comics and those comics
are considered legends you know
non-canon but uh the planet did get
mentioned in the clone wars novelization
the uh revenge of the sith uh
novelization and it is mentioned in
these empire comics so during the clone
wars era it's you know it's described as
a rainy muddy mining planet that joins
the separatists the empire comics use it
as a setting during the galactic civil
war which actually would be set years
after this series um so hopefully we see
this planet it's you know a really
really cool location
hopefully that's where they're headed
next um but it may be unrelated but
tommy and i were able to see that uh
exclusive ahsoka footage at celebration
and showed a quick shot of hu yang which
i just think is very interesting because
he is the architect droid who's on the
jedi ship called the crucible who uh his
job was to train jedi younglings so if
huyang survived
some of those jedi young ladies may have
also survived and quinlan could be part
of the network that helps get those kids
to a new safe life and safe identities
um so i'm so excited to see quinlan be
in charge of this operation uh and it
was interesting how obi-wan read this
quote that said only when the eyes are
closed can you truly see and leia asks
see what he goes the way and if you look
at the closed captioning way is
capitalized uh now that could be
referring to the way right uh the like
the jedi way the path um and the fact
that
you cannot be looking at it you have to
meditate you have to be a bit blind to
see the path right as obi-wan is now in
the blind he doesn't know what's ahead
right you can't project the future all
the jedi are blind right and that
harkens back to um you know the jedi
orthodoxy of like blinding
their uh
their padawans their apprentices as they
try to use the force to sense things
right as luke had to wear the blind
helmet uh on the millennium falcon um
but the fact that he says the way it's
just hard not to see it as a parallel to
the watch this is the way you know yep
uh and the exclusive mandalorian season
three footage that we saw at star wars
celebration showed boca ton telling
mando that his cult abandoned mandalore
long before the purge and we don't know
exactly how his watch cult started we
know that it was derived from the death
watch but it's a different group of
mandalorians right than the ones that we
start with in the mandalorian series
i'm one and i'm totally reaching here
i'm just saying there could be a link
here
uh quinlan vos
smuggling unknowing force sensitive kids
to safety telling them hide yourself as
obi-wan told uh uh betty sathy's jedi
character like forever mask yourself and
that might be why again i'm reaching i
know this could be why these mandalorian
families with the watch
mask themselves with best guard and are
not allowed to take off their helmets
that could be uh young force sensitive
kids don't realize they're force
sensitive uh and why they are so
cult-like and devout uh in their
approach to the mandalorian way of life
uh these could be these escaped jedi
foundlings uh who quinlan voss gets to
save passage to the armorer and now
maybe that could be why the dark saber
it's bound has found itself to din
jaren's hands because the dark saber was
created by the original mandalorian jedi
again i'm reaching that's just where my
mind is going right now
think it's time
you are blowing you blew my mind that is
incredible i love that i really want
that to be what happened
i want dinjarin to be force sensitive i
want him to be a force-sensitive little
boy and i want i know a lot of people
are going to say like it's better when
people are not force sensitive because
they kind of hate it when like so many
people are force sensitive i get that it
could it could just be like he was part
of that same operation he ended up not
really having or his midichlorians are
like no they deactivated or something or
they weren't
but i
i think that could be part of the same
operation all right
well i love that theory eric and i hope
that anyone that's gonna be negative
about it
trips and stubs their toe on a coffee
table today with my powers of the force
yeah i i just think like that could be
why the uh the armorer was just trying
to stamp out like she seems so anti-jedi
right
she calls them like culti wizards yeah
uh and she's part of her own cult right
right so that might be why like she's
just trying to make sure the members of
the watch survive
um
um but this wouldn't be all the members
of the watch right so we have we have uh
paz visla who's just a member of house
wiesla who ended up joining this watch i
think some of the people they adopt
maybe could be part of this quinlan vos
network but another obvious path for for
quinlan vos is just like there could be
some colony out there of jedi who were
able to survive
um do you think it's more likely that
there is like a witness protection
program that just scatters them across
yeah i feel like that's way more i mean
like the idea of putting them all in a
colony to me seems like making them
sitting ducks again
that's a good point that's a good point
i mean i just i'm just saying the way my
brain from watching crime dramas works
you know i don't necessarily know that
the star wars it's more fun in the star
wars universe if there's just this like
cool outdoor community where like young
force sensitive kids are like leaping
over the monkey bars instead of climbing
them like you know i'd rather that
happen but you know a xavier's school
for gifted exactly yeah you know
i just wonder like you know if they are
just hunting for sensitive kids and if
they have any kind of holocron that can
identify force sensitive kids aren't are
they more protected scattered the way
leia and luke are are they more
protected like
with uh in some kind of group home it's
a good question i don't know
yeah i guess
i mean to do it the scattered way you
kind of need to assign them a chaperone
like each one kind of needs an older
jedi to then
also take out a new identity and hide
out like we saw what happened with like
a rule of two you might say yeah oh a
master and an apprentice wait a second
wait we've tried that
oh hey you can't fail a second time i
just want to know why they're going to
jabin like jabin's kind of a [ __ ]
it's just a muddy
uh like
muddy gross mining
i hope we get more frog people you know
frogs love mud
i love mud i'm a pig and [ __ ] in mud
um okay there's a lot more to talk about
coming out of this episode but we want
to remind you all the new rockstars is
on tumblr whether you're new to tumblr
or a long time user be sure to check out
the official new rockstars tumblr page
all this month we're gonna be talking
about the miss marvel series launched on
disney plus so be sure to stop on by and
uh check out our tumblr page also big
announcement here the boys underground
our weekly show our weekly after show
for the boys on amazon uh returns this
week with the premiere the first three
episodes and it's gonna be hosted by our
man tom bechdel
back in the underground
and special guests every week and it's
gonna come out i believe on fridays uh
sometime friday midday friday afternoon
so uh be sure to check out boys
underground right here on new rockstars
youtube channel you can also subscribe i
believe to uh boys underground wherever
you get your podcasts so i'm very
excited we can't wait jessica and i are
already scheming plotting all right
tommy let's talk about the inquisitors
this episode
it seems like the grand inquisitor is
being treated as dead or at least
incapacitated yeah
is this show strength retconning the
grand inquisitor from uh him being alive
in rebels i mean it just depends because
there is a part that of like logic from
what we know from jedi's or sith or
people that have the power of the force
and have harnessed it they'd be able to
sense if he was still alive right like
there would be a part like i think only
vader knows the truth i think only vader
knows the reality i think you know darth
vader is he's treacherous in the i mean
we have
movie after movie of him being
treacherous it's not without
uh possibility that he's telling the
third sister all of these things to get
what he wants from her all while healing
the grand inquisitor in another room you
know what i mean like in being like
don't worry we will we will strike back
and like you know we'll get you right
back in you know when we need you most
because i could see this ending up being
something where like the third
inquisitor riva ends up on her own
little thing like it ends up being vader
grand inquisitor obi-wan
and riva and like a you know a triangle
of conflict
uh because riva doesn't really obey
she's rebellious and she you know she
doesn't follow order she does whatever
she wants so yes she goes rogue she did
it this episode she went rogue from
vader and she kind of went off on her
own but she's successful that's you
can't take that away from her absolutely
not and i i'm it's not a criticism of
the character i just i could see
it becoming something where like it's a
different adversary you know what i mean
like she's no longer working as an
inquisitor she's now just working as
someone bent on vengeance
so yeah
let's game this out like how they could
still stay true to the canonical
continuity of the grand inquisitor and
rebels so like riva would have to fail
uh or be or just kind of go rogue
or like turn against vader and disappear
and escape his wrath and then the grand
inquisitor would have to be reinstated
in power but he seems to be like super
weak right if he is alive he's on life
support or he's like in a back to tank
somewhere uh it'd just be weird to
incapacitate him for these middle
episodes
just to restore him at the end of the
series like is that an interesting story
for the character like i don't know
maybe it'll just be simpler next episode
or in the three episodes ahead it's just
like a very weird move to do this i i
hope it's not the last episode i hope
it's either next episode or the fifth
episode and we get him for two more at
least but yeah well it's just power
status wise it's weird for riva to still
stay as powerful as she is and then
bring the grand inquisitor back like
sure the guy's gonna be like uh the
coach in winning time who hits his head
after a bike ride right right right he
comes back in the scene and they're like
just just retire just why i i think it
can only happen if riva is
pushed out you know like if vader is
like you've disobeyed you're out she has
to be seen as a usurper and all the
inquisitors do her as an ins and i think
they already i mean the sentiment
against her is already fairly negative
right like we do seem to be heading
towards that but you know in the i mean
the empire historically like
there's a lot of people inside plotting
to betray each other to rise up like
it's not it's not exactly an ethical
organization i would say yeah
i think i mean look star wars has um
retconned things before um obviously you
know the lucas film team has changed
certain things about uh whether han shot
first right um they uh it's just it's
not that common that in the filoni era
of star wars that we see these kind of
retcons happening to maloney's own stuff
like filoni was not an executive
producer on this show but he did get a
special thanks in the credits right
anybody believe that he's at least
consulting on the star wars floor and
it's still pablo hidalgo is consulting
on all the the star wars continuity so
like it'd be weird for him just be like
yeah kill off the grand inquisitor
because i think all these people were
also working on rebels and know where
the grand inquisitor's future is i don't
buy the argument that it's a different
uh powen no then this grant i think that
would be a weird thing because in star
wars rebels imply that that power that
we saw in star wars rebels season one
was the same one who came out of the
jedi temple right um so it'd be weird
for this one on obi-wan kenobi to just
be a different grand inquisitor
yeah
my my fear is that that moment was just
meant to be a shocking like twist of
like oh you thought the grand inquisitor
was going to be this nefarious force
but no he's actually dead and it's it's
the third sister
and and and and and i'm and i'm somehow
missing that you know like i'm just yeah
not taking action
if they do truly kill off the grand
inquisitor so this will be the biggest
retcon that we've ever seen in this era
of star wars absolutely like you can say
that like oh well jango fett was changed
from being a mandalorian or mandalorian
or not you know because filoni said that
django fett wasn't uh meant to be seen
as a mandalorian but then uh made a
lawyer in season two to find that he was
from a mandalorian uh from concord dawn
um that i think is just something just
for nerds this is something that is
straight up confusing for anyone who's
watched rebels right you know yep um so
anyway i guess we'll see maybe we're
just like spending too much time on it
let's talk about this question of
obi-wan's family yeah obi-wan's brother
could we meet obi-wan's brother in the
future and if so would he be
force-sensitive that's a great question
i mean honestly it's like
he has memories that he had a brother he
says or glimpses what he calls them more
like flashes or whatever they're not
even memories anymore
i i it's tough to say again like it
would be really cool to have another
kenobi out there like there's just like
you know and
what what is this person doing i mean he
would be younger right he said he
thought he had a younger brother so it
would be right he remembers a baby yeah
i mean look most uh jedi are taken from
when they're toddlers like they're you
know when we met anakin skywalker or
before the jedi high council met anakin
he was nine and they're like oh he's too
old right they're like gross very gross
for them um so they're taken when
they're like three years old so his
memories would be kind of spotty from
there but yeah here's what i'll say
i like that this came up i do not ever
need to meet obi-wan that's brother i
don't think so either i to me this is
like oh dumbledore had a brother right
yeah i'm going to age my charlie had a
brother from city slicker's universe
like right i don't need this curly had a
brother duke who looked just like him
but i uh yeah i also think it's a bit of
a like
it would be a bit of a like this is
going to age myself terribly but you
know like a cousin oliver addition to a
sitcom where you're like let's just keep
adding family members to this show to
like make it interesting instead of just
adding new conflict to the existing
characters so right yeah i like the
mention i like flushing out fleshing out
obi-wan as a human or as a you know as a
character who once had a family and went
through the same trauma of being taken
by the taken by the jedi i never need to
hear about it again yeah i i leave that
as a mystery leave that as much of a
mystery as uh yoda's and grogu's species
it's he's out there somewhere we never
need to meet him and then we can keep
talking about them all as much as we
want
um okay let's talk about the way vader
was shown this episode uh we briefly saw
hayden christensen's face we saw him
both uh his scarred head under the mask
we also saw this weird uh apparition of
him on one of the hills in mapuzo yeah
just wearing a nice billowing jedi cloak
uh pretty creepy right to be honest with
you um but other than that it was really
just the voice of james earl jones but
i'm pretty sure that was hayden
christensen in the suit doing all the
physical work right unless they want to
bring in a stunt guy but i think him
like marching down that uh that street
way yeah on mapuzo i think he was he's
the one choking well they made the point
to mention that he worked with a
movement coach right as we covered on
the break room yesterday but uh they uh
so yeah it wouldn't make sense i mean
it's
i i gave all credit to him for wanting
to reprise that role and get in the suit
but it's like
if you're a fan of hayden christians in
the actor you're not getting a ton of
like you know
performance
in terms of you know seeing his face and
like you know you're getting you're
getting a very i guess just a physical
uh recapturing of vader which is
impressive in its own right yeah i think
it speaks to uh what a good sport hayden
is for wanting to be part of this yeah
and obviously yeah they're bringing back
uh the character and we have three more
episodes to see of vader i'm just trying
to think like practically what kind of
scenes can we see with him yeah this
show has given us two ways or i guess
really three ways you can see him right
you can see him through flashback you
can see him scarred under the mask but
like he's not going to be uh maskless
when he's out of the back to tank right
and that's like a private chamber it's
really only him and his creepy little
assistant
like no one obi-wan is not going to be
in there right
so are we just going to see these weird
apparitions that uh that'll be worse my
thought is that the last time that they
physically meet obi-wan might debilitate
him to the point where he does take his
mask off you know what i mean obi-wan
once again has him against the robes
kind of like in the final
in in return of the jedi when vader
requests luke to take his mask off but
obi-wan
anakin's not requesting it it just
happens and then perhaps obi-wan takes
mercy on him puts the mask back like he
can't kill his friend but like we get
that oh maybe you know that's the only
that's just me
reaching for a way that that could
happen yeah yeah uh i mean they could
show us a new way where we show like a
super close-up of hayden under the mask
right like in the iron man heads-up
display yeah but we haven't seen that
yet on this series um yeah i just uh i
like that hayden is part of this i
especially like his physical performance
yeah um so i will say it feels like
vader ultimately because you'd need
james earl jones voice to come through
that mask it just would not be the same
absolutely um but like i am
part of the appeal for the show was like
hey hayden's coming back as a character
right and i want to see
hayden's acting like his face his his
emotional reaction to things and i want
to know like you had to bring hayden
back for this right and i want i'm
hoping that the series gives us a few
moments just a few moments where it's
like that's why they brought back here
yep you know and i don't think this
episode gave us that yet no not yet but
we got time not yet we have three more
episodes though i can't wait to dig in
them uh into them because i'll say like
this is a fascinating experience oh a
show
uh it it feels like i'm dreaming right
now the fact that we're getting these
actors back and they're hanging out with
young leia and they're all in the same
place and this is star wars history that
we're seeing this is always part of the
star wars story and it's just being
revealed to us it's very very exciting
um but we'll leave it there for this
episode of wikileaks the easter egg
breakdown will be coming out tomorrow on
the show um don't forget to check out
our many great merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me at ea boss
follow tommy tommy beck told follow new
rockstar subscribe to wikileaks wherever
you get your podcasts thank you for
watching and
you